lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ver una forma más rigurosa de definir la
continuidad ya hemos visto una idea muy
general de la continuidad que nos dice
que si podemos dibujar a esa función sin
separar el lápiz del papel en ese punto
entonces la función en ese punto es
continua lo que acabo de decir no es una
definición rigurosa de hecho no es nada
formal lo que estaba diciendo pero de
todas formas vamos a repetirlo si
tenemos por aquí un punto llamémosle ese
y una función y podemos dibujar esa
función sin separar el lápiz del papel
mientras estoy pasando justo por ese
punto entonces la función es continua si
tenemos esta función podemos empezar por
aquí y dibujar la función sin separar el
lápiz o en todo caso la pluma del papel
y listo
pasamos por este valor de x dibujando la
función sin tener que levantar el
del papel entonces podemos decir que la
función es continua en ese punto pero
por otro lado si tuviéramos otra función
que se viera más o menos así si por
ejemplo empieza por acá y sube y sube y
en el valor se aquí tenemos un pequeño
brinco que salta hasta por acá y luego
sigue subiendo y subiendo bueno pues
esta nueva función sería muy difícil
dibujarla sin levantar el lápiz cuando
llegamos a hacer porque por ejemplo si
empezamos por aquí aquí mi lápiz no se
despega del papel y estamos dibujando la
función pero cuando llegamos aquí como
le vamos a hacer para seguir dibujando
la función sin levantar el lápiz del
papel no se puede cierto necesitamos
levantar el lápiz del papel y colocarlo
por acá y ahora sí podemos seguir
dibujando la función así es que esa es
una forma intuitiva de saber que esta
función no es continua
en este punto bueno pero ahora vamos a
ver una definición formal de la
continuidad
vamos a ver qué tanto concuerda con
nuestra intuición entonces vamos a ver
esa definición de continuidad esa
definición formal vamos a empezar por la
definición de continuidad en un solo
punto la función f es continua en el
punto x igual a c si sólo si el límite
por ambos lados
conforme x tiende a c de fx es igual a
la función evaluada en c ahora esta
definición que tenemos aquí se ve
demasiado técnica por lo que vamos a ver
parte por parte qué es lo que nos está
diciendo aquí lo que nos dice es que si
el límite por la derecha y por la
izquierda
conforme x tiende hace de la función es
exactamente igual a la función evaluada
en el punto c entonces la función es
continua en ese punto y también nos dice
que si la función es continua
entonces el límite de la función es
igual a la función evaluada en el punto
vamos a ver tres ejemplos distintos
vamos a ver un ejemplo en el que
utilizando esto que estábamos viendo que
nos dice nuestra intuición de que una
función es continua si podemos dibujar
su gráfica sin levantar el lápiz del
papel y vamos a ver otros dos ejemplos
en donde claramente tenemos que levantar
el lápiz para seguir dibujando esa
función
tenemos el eje y el eje x y digamos que
esta es nuestra función ye igual a efe
de x y lo que nos interesa de esta
función es su comportamiento cuando x es
igual a c aunque yo esté es elegir x y
este es el eje entonces nos importa el
comportamiento de esta función cuando x
es igual a c por acá si utilizamos la
técnica de ver si tenemos que levantar
el lápiz o no parece como que esta
función si es continua en este punto que
nos interesa porque esta gráfica por lo
menos cerca de este punto c
de estar conectada no podemos ver ningún
salto ninguna discontinuidad así es que
parece ser una función continua en este
punto c pero ahora lo interesante es
ponernos a pensar en la definición
formal de continuidad en un punto y cómo
se relaciona con esta gráfica empecemos
por el límite cuando x tiende a c de fx
este límite tiene dos partes el límite
cuando x tiende a ser por la izquierda y
el límite cuando x tiene hace por la
derecha entonces vamos a empezar por el
límite cuando x tiende a c por la
izquierda
conforme x se aproxima a c por la
izquierda parece como que los valores de
fx tienden al valor fdc aunque hay por
aquí tenemos el valor fcc y también
conforme nos acercamos por la derecha
los valores de f parecen estar
aproximándose al valor
efe de c y además la función si está
definida en x igual hace sus valores
bbc que está aquí y si coincide con el
valor al que tiende el límite por la
izquierda y por la derecha entonces
podemos decir que el límite cuando x
tiende a c de fx si es igual al valor de
la función en ese punto
fcc y entonces la función f si es
continua en ese punto pero bueno ahora
vamos a ver otros ejemplos en los que si
tratamos de dibujar a la función cuando
nos acercamos a cierto punto vamos a
tener que levantar el lápiz para poder
seguir dibujando la función aunque hay
vamos a tener que levantar el lápiz
cuando pasamos por ese punto en
específico que ahí vamos a ver un
ejemplo en el que tenemos una cosa a la
que le llamamos un punto de
discontinuidad por el momento todavía no
necesita saber cuál es la definición
formal de los puntos de discontinuidad
pero bueno vamos a ver los digamos que
el punto usted se encuentra por acá y
que la función se ve más o menos así y
el valor de la función en el punto c
se encuentra por acá este de acá es fcc
el valor de la función evaluada en el
punto c pero cuál es el límite conforme
x tiende a c de la función cuál es el
límite conforme x tiene hace de fx y
este límite por cierto es el límite por
los dos lados pero a ver conforme x
tiende hace por la izquierda aquí lo que
parece es que nos estamos aproximando a
este valor y si tomamos el límite por la
derecha
conforme x tiende a c por la derecha
también parece como que nos estamos
aproximando a este mismo valor entonces
a este valor le podríamos llamar el ok
ese es el valor l y el límite l es un
valor distinto a fcc entonces lo que nos
dice nuestra definición formal de
continuidad en un punto como no está
sucediendo esto de acá la definición nos
dice que f
no es continua en la función f no es
continua en el punto x igual hace si
queremos dibujar esta función con un
lápiz y un papel
empezamos por aquí no nos estamos
despegando del papel pero cuando
llegamos acá y tenemos que dibujar el
valor de defense pero éste se encuentra
más arriba entonces vamos a tener que
separar el lápiz del papel dibujar el
valor defense y ahora además si queremos
seguir dibujando la función tenemos que
volver a saltar y regresar a este punto
y ahora sí podemos continuar dibujando
la gráfica de esta función entonces la
función no es continua y esta definición
formal nos está dando exactamente la
misma conclusión aquí lo que estamos
viendo es que el límite cuando x tiende
a c por la izquierda y por la derecha
tenemos aquí es el límite
es distinto al valor de la función en
este punto es distinto a fcc y por lo
tanto la función no es continua no es
continua bueno ahora vamos con otro
escenario ahora vamos a ver un escenario
en el que ni siquiera existe el límite
por ambos lados aquí están los ejes x y
ye y digamos que nuestra función hace
algo de este estilo que yo por acá está
nuestro valor cuando x es igual a c este
de aquí es fcc y si en efecto si nos
fijamos en el límite cuando x tiende a c
por la izquierda de fx este límite si es
igual a la función evaluada en c pero si
nos fijamos en el límite por la derecha
el límite cuando x tiende a c por la
derecha este límite se aproxima a este
valor al que le llamamos l entonces el
límite cuando x tiende a c por la
derecha de fx
es igual a él y él es distinta de fcc lo
que hay aquí lo podemos ver claramente y
cuando tenemos esta situación en la que
el límite por la izquierda es distinto
que el límite por la derecha el límite
por los dos lados no existe porque nos
estamos aproximando a dos valores
distintos cuando nos aproximamos por la
izquierda y cuando nos aproximamos por
la derecha entonces como el límite
definitivamente no existe
definitivamente no es una función
continua y esto también concuerda con
nuestra prueba intuitiva acerca de
tratar de dibujar la función sin
levantar el lápiz ok porque empezamos
por aquí el lápiz se queda en el papel
sigue pegado al papel pero aquí acabamos
de llegar hace y ahora para poder seguir
dibujando la función pues tenemos que
hacer un salto lo que tenemos que saltar
hasta acá porque si nos quedamos por acá
no podemos terminar de dibujar la
función ok entonces tomamos el lápiz lo
separamos del papel
lo ponemos por acá y seguimos dibujando
pero entonces nuestra función no es
continua no es continua si usamos la
definición de tratar de dibujar la
gráfica sin despegar el lápiz del papel
y
tampoco es continua si utilizamos esta
definición formal en este caso el límite
cuando x tiende a c por los dos lados ni
siquiera existe entonces la función
definitivamente no es continua según
esta definición formal ahora siempre que
tenemos una función incluso aunque este
límite exista por ejemplo aquí tenemos
una función cuyo límite por los dos
lados si existe si es el límite resulta
ser distinto que el valor de la función
entonces la función tampoco es continua
la única forma en la que una función es
continuar en un punto es si el límite
por ambos lados existe y tiende hacia el
mismo valor que tiene la función en ese
punto si eso es cierto la función es
continua y también si la función es
continua eso también va a ser cierto así
es que ya terminamos